brother
alikum my question is regarding
Insurance actually some say the
insurance is allowed some say it's not
allowed now I work in a company where by
default we get insured myself my family
the spouse Etc and part of the salary is
taken in as a premium so we don't have
an option now in case there is a medical
requirement can I Avail the benefits of
insurance for myself and my
family ask two parts of the question
first part that medical insurance is
allowed or not or is insurance Haram or
Halal and secondly since this company
has forced him into a policy of
insurance from his salary so can he
Avail of the benefits as far as the
first question is concerned regarding is
Insurance allowed or not per se
insurance is not
Haram it is mub it's option it's Halal
Insurance per se but because most of the
insurance they involve interest or
that's why it becomes Haram so business
per se is halal allowed but if the
business deals with alcohol it becomes
Haram if the business deals with RBA it
becomes Haram the similar Insurance per
say is not Haram but because most of the
insurance is based on R it's connected
with interest therefore it's Haram there
are many Islamic insurance companies
which I know in Oman and Dubai many
there are many which I'm aware of so if
it's based on the Islamic Sharia
guidelines Insurance per se is allowed
but in India also most of them which I
know of they deal with they it becomes
Haram now as far as in your case if
you're working in a company and they say
that you have to take out a medical
insurance and they cut from your salary
and then can you Avail the benefits see
there are many things which are rules of
a
company which you have an option to
Avail or not and some place you don't
have option as far as medical insurance
is concerned if the company Cuts I feel
if you go and approach the management
and say I don't mind insurance but
because it is Haram in our community
please don't cut my salary first thing
you have to check up with the medical
insurance that a company has involved in
is it haram or Halal most of them are
Haram so
you can request them that se that to
choose a company which is halal see one
thing is the life insurance in life
insurance what happen that whatever
premium you pay there are some Clauses
to it it may be 10 years life insurance
so they keep on paying a fixed amount of
Premium every month and if the policy
matures after 10 years if you don't die
you get the same amount
back but if you die in between you may
get double if an extent you may get more
so depends upon the policy so this
surely what money you give it comes back
to it interest based most of the others
also interest based in a medical
insurance you pay amount whether you get
sick or not if you don't get sick you
don't get the amount back so depending
on what the policies and what is the
basis of it to give you money back
because if they're giving you money for
treatment they have to acquire from
somewhere else if there's Islamic
pooling where you say that everyone
gives a th000 rupees and if there are
hundreds of thousands of people and if
one person gets sick you give that Mone
so that becomes Halal but most of the
insurance company don't work like that
they take your money and they invest and
they keep it in a bank and they get
interest out of it so if the money
that's taken from you the premium taken
from you if it is invested in a business
which is not Haram then the policy is
halal but most of the insurance company
they keep it in a bank for safety and
they take interest which becomes Haram
so which medical company has your
company taken the insurance off you have
to check up most I know that I can't say
100% And if it's a Haram falling Haram
category surely you can go and speak to
the management and say that see I know
that it is for my benefit that if I give
a medical insurance claim my money is
being cut maybe a few hundred rupees but
any problem so you can give in writing
that please don't cut my medical
insurance claim and if any medical
expenses I will bear from my own salary
if you given wrting a doubt whether any
company will object now that's the
difference in the people don't go and
speak to the management that
way so there's no rule of the government
that the company should take medical
claim from you it is the policy of the
company and if you're able to convince
to the company say this is my religion
it is Haram no muslim may have come and
told them that explain to them majority
I think inshallah most of them will
agree with the demand and there are many
such cases which I have guided people in
other aspects like offering Salah you go
and request why won't they accept it but
speak in a good way that if you are
taking a few minutes for Salah say I
will work extra for that see to it that
the work is not Disturbed see to it that
you better output so if performance is
good the company will not mind exceeding
to your request but
generally taking a insurance policy of
anything which involves a is not allow
in Islam